Okay.
So when we look at the system of toxicants versus,
uh,
other toxicants,
a systematic toxicant is one that's going to affect the entirety of your body.
Okay?
So when you start thinking about something like a potassium cyanide that is
going to affect a cell's ability,
to absorb and utilize oxygen [inaudible] uh,
that's going to be something that's not unique to any particular organ.
That is going to be a systemic effect.
Okay.
Um,
target specific toxicants are going to,
uh,
as,
as it would suggest go after a particular,
um,
uh,
organ or tissue.
For instance,
when we,
uh,
we started thinking about the central nervous system.
Led is a particular target organ at,
uh,
letters,
a particular agent for central nervous system development.
Um,
mercury can be a central nervous system.
toxicant when we start thinking about classes of chemicals such as ISO sinaits,
they may affect the immune system,
ethanol and Acetaminophen.
The liver tobacco smoke as best as ozone,
all can affect the respiratory tract and under a UV light can affect the eyes.
Various metals can affect the kidney.
Um,
and,
uh,
give the example here of they promo chloral propane is in fact in reproductive
dough.
So what we're looking at is different pathways to manifest toxicity.
Some can go throughout your whole body,
some will affect specific target organs.
What is some of the factors,
again,
key slide,
the factors affecting chemical toxicity.
So the uh,
the form and the inherent,
um,
chemical activity of some,
how reactive is the chemical,
how Seibel as the chemical.
Uh,
when we talk about the electronic properties and the polarizability,
all of those factors are important.
The form of the substance,
whether or not the substance is a gas,
a liquid,
a solid,
when you start thinking about the kind of toxicity,
uh,
related to nano toxicity nanoparticles,
whether those substances are of a certain size and aspect ratio aspect ratio
being the,
um,
the combination of Linkedin with,
uh,
that's important to as best as that's to mammals substitutes.
So the character of the molecules itself are going to be a crucial,
um,
about whether or not there's going to be toxic.
Uh,
we already talked about dosage and the um,
uh,
the amount of time of that dose
exposure route.
So the same substance if,
uh,
if swallowed versus inhaled,
um,
uh,
versus rubbed on your skin
or any other route,
uh,
can have different,
different effects,
the ability to be absorbed,
uh,
something that uh,
they'd can't be absorbed,
can't cause toxic effects.
The metabolism rate,
whether or not you're able to break this down into something that is non toxic.
So the activation that's going to affect it,
a distribution within the body,
again,
if it only stays within your digestive system,
it gets excreted,
can't spread to other organs.
It's not going to,
um,
uh,
be able to cause a problem,
excretion rate directly related to that presence of other chemicals.
This is something that we're going to return to.
So are you ever exposed to one chemical at a time?
No.
We're all swimming in a sea of chemicals all the time.
What you eat,
what you breathe.
All of those things can either,
uh,
affect things in our,
in a positive way from a,
um,
from a,
uh,
toxicological standpoint or negative.
In other words,
a toxicant can be chaperoned across a biological membrane.
We're going to talk a lot more about that in just a minute,
but simply saying,
oh,
this substance is toxic or not toxic isn't always the whole story.